we're advising today that the
booster program is extended to persons
age 40 to 49 years as well
as previously
the boosted dose is advised six months
after the second dose
and either the fisa beyond type vaccine
or the moderna vaccine can be used as
the booster dose regardless of the type
of vaccine received for the first two
doses in the primary cause
i'd like to just mention the
dose used for the moderna booster
the dose used is 50 micrograms which is
half the dose used in the primary cause
which was a hundred or is a hundred
micrograms
this use of a lower dose
of vaccine for the boosted dose is a
recognized method of boosting
vaccine-induced immunity
it has been used for years and is
continuing to be used now in other
routine immunization programs such as
the booster doses used in against
diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis this is not an
unusual thing to do
a lower dose for the booster dose
is a very
usual method of boosting the immune
system
for the moderna vaccine we also know
that studies have been done
looking at the lower dose or half dose
booster dose of moderna and after the
third booster dose sorry after the third
dose which is a booster dose the immune
response is far higher than after the
second dose so we know that this half
dose as a booster works very well